what is happening reject nation it is
that time of the week
where we watch from eric voss a new rock
star's more easter eggs and breakdown
for
falcon and winter soldier where he gets
to share
his skills with uh
if you guys haven't heard of skillshare
from this person this person
this person this person and this person
then let us tell you what skillshare is
all about
skillshare is the online learning
community with literally
thousands of courses here to help you
unlock your creativity explore new
skills
and expand your existing interests
whether you're honing inspiration for a
creative passion project
or just trying to avoid some boredom
skillshare has a course for you it was
actually pretty difficult to pick a
class to shout out for this video there
are a ton
of really worthwhile ones wait you
picked out a class yeah
i played i didn't see high top film
since we get so many questions about how
to grow a channel i think the perfect
course for you guys out there would be
marquez brownlee's youtube success
course marquez walks you through the
whole process from theorizing your first
video to shooting editing
posting channel growth wait this is all
real
this is real i usually just skip when
people talk about skill shirts
beneficial information you could have
learned something from the shout out
alone
i mean from my understanding the first
thousand people that is
one less than one thousand one to use
our special link
in the description box guess what guess
what what we got you'll never guess this
you're gonna get a free trial for
skillshare premium
membership free dang i thought you were
gonna say like a parking space
or something no no no we uh we have run
out of parking spaces
and this street is full after the free
trial it's only about 10 bucks a month
there are no ads or anything so it's all
about the knowledge
so go grow your brain sign up today
[Music]
totally not shooting this on a different
day now it's just mere moments after
totally not dealing with food poisoning
at the moment either
no you're you're not welcome back to new
rock stars i'm eric voss and this is a
breakdown of the falcon in the winter
soldier episode 5
truth in which julia louie drives john
and i just said walker more dumb struck
than a shield of the face
i'm going to explain your big questions
and break down all the subtle details
that you might have missed in this
episode so we open on john
mississippi sprint just like that winter
soldier opens for sam wilson and steve
rogers in the middle of their runs
except this cap is running from his
problems not
interested in making friends i wonder if
that is an intentional mirror
yeah maybe
it's a it's a poetic parallel poser
henry jackman recalls his music from
captain america civil war
you also hear this light motif later
[Music]
this whole fight mirrors that two-on-one
fight that ended that film
in which bucky teams up to take down a
rival who is filled with rage over
a dead loved one now sam's focus goes to
the blood still on the shield
john yeah notice that i think the
biggest difference with captain
america's civil war is that i mean
there's a lot of big differences in
terms of the context of what
captain america is in it with the shield
smashing kind of mirroring captain
america civil war
seat with iron man and then have that
also mirrored
that famous fight scene between the
three of them but what was neat is like
oh these are all
stems of captain america that are
fighting with each other right now you
know it's cut off one captain america
three moral takes
what is that vibranium hums a sound
effect they often do with the shield
that indicate it's kind of weird
mystical qualities
but here it's oh i like this spirit is
dismayed at these stains
now bucky tries to calm john don't go
down that road
believe me it doesn't end well i'm not
like you
yeah notice how bucky just takes this in
biting his tongue letting the other two
talk for a bit and he only speaks up
once more
and the last line spoken right before
punches are thrown
you don't want to do this
yeah we do but we got to break down this
fight move by move because
everything is amazing early on bucky
grapples with walker and goes for his
gun
smartly disarming him as soon as
possible and he knocks that gun loose
but in response walker in slow motion
raises the shield to bring it down on
bucky's head
just like he did to nico so we're
freaking out but
we're freaking out
walker brings that shield down on sam
this time until bucky returns the favor
i love the way sam you
that's like john walker's power but like
when you know like a couple of buttons
in a
video game like but i know that with
this strong character you'll do this
awesome powerball
you know and if you see him charging up
for it you got to try and get it hit it
before he does it otherwise you're dead
you can't just keep going for that one
move john walker is what we're trying to
tell you expand your repertoire don't be
a button yeah open up that combo list
dude
there's a move list on every fighting
game up up down down left right
i love the way sam uses his wings in
this fight first using one to slap that
shield out of walker's left hand
and then later sam backspins on his
wings to tripwalker
and when walker throws the shield at
bucky knocks him off his feet bucky
catches the shield
and briefly wields it if you think about
it every time on the series when john
walker
flings something at bucky but he can't
always catches it walker throws him
smashes his vibranium arm causing it to
glitch briefly though it appears to
recover shortly after
sam tries to tether this shield similar
to how peter parker
webbed the shield in civil war out of
cap's hands but it doesn't work walker
pins him rips off his wings
and they restrain walker who tried to
pull the shield off his arm
similar to the avengers dog piling on
thanos to remove the infinity gauntlet
until inevitably using the force of
sam's jet pack they freaking break his
arm
so people what i love about the effect
of falcon's wings being ripped out
it feels like they are an extension of
him himself so it feels like a physical
part of his limbs his body
is actually being ripped off yeah it
still feels like a wound but it feels
like it's
like it's just an extension of his body
so you're like oh that hurts even though
he's not
feeling physical pain from it yeah it
feels that way and i think that's really
effective if you think about it though
steve rogers arm was also broken as he
bought thanos and in-game remember there
was that close-up where he tightened the
shield
as a tourniquet yeah so surely steve
fused the shield with himself to make
himself whole
whereas walker breaks himself over his
attachment to that shield i mean
throughout the mcu one of the best
things about this shield is the way it's
been used in collabs
and here is another collab for those
books
now bucky drops the shield for sam
another mirror of the way cap dropped
this shield for tony in civil war and as
he does this he is bathed in these
beams of sunlight of getting steve's
blessing to return his spiritual symbol
to its rightful place so right on that
drop a little glimmer of light reflects
off the shield
and as bucky walks off listen again to
the music
that's brilliant
[Music]
yeah the composer is bringing back the
end of the line music that he composed
for captain america winter soldier that
was the moment when cap dropped the
shield to show
his friendship to bucky i'm not gonna
fight i love how much this journey is
mirrored to captain america yeah
seriously the films yeah later on toria
sells bucky
hey you got your uh you got your sleeve
back he's calling back bucky tearing off
his sleeve before that dumb jump out of
the plane in episode two
and santa tells stories to take these
broken wings
wait yo you forgot the wings okay keep
him
yeah does become a version of the falcon
in the comics when sam becomes captain
america
so we could be whatever happens he
better have that actual
falcon on his shoulder that's what i'm
saying yeah always
always even in the heat of battle and
they better use practical falcons
well yeah i will not settle for cgi
title character the real falcon the real
falcon not the title character that fat
falcon
yeah that yeah on his shoulder the real
falcon then what was your thing about
this actually the actual
yeah oh the actual file the real oh i
thought you were talking about like
doesn't seem
to be the bird this is what we call a
misunderstanding in the real region and
it made the joke better
yeah let's see if it stays in the video
so we could be looking at the origin for
new falcon i mean sam's line here like
tony's moment with that pre-recast
roadie and iron man
next time baby oh more like next time
you're looking for this walker
some combination of the joint chiefs
maybe with the chairman of the senate
armed forces committee because he's a
senator they're military people maybe
this is a government body representing
the u.s delegation to the grc look it's
post blip who knows how government works
then walker goes kavanagh
i lived my life those camps by your
mandates i dedicated
my life to your mandate and then a very
cold
you built me yeah through walker's rage
we are given a
clear reference point for isaiah bradley
who was another super soldier who's just
following orders but in his case he was
not allowed to walk free so what does
john walker have to complain about
then walker is approached by cameo alert
a little cameo
seinfeld and veep star julia louie
dreyfus
contessa valentina here we go so you can
just call me val
but don't call me val just keep it in
your head yes contessa valentina allegra
de fontaine is a longtime shield agent
in the marvel comics often associated
with nick fury she goes by agent 14 and
at another point
she's definitely gonna wear that costume
but that was really a short-lived
mission when she was actually part of
the leviathan and she was betraying
hydra undermining them
folks is a lesser known figure and a lot
of folks right now are jumping on her
being out of hydra confirmed but that
article is really just a small part of
her run
like she plays a big role in secret
invasion replaced by a skrull who really
kicks off nick fury's initial suspicions
she works on a femme force team with
sharon carter you could jump to the
conclusion that she
is the power broker this show has been
hinting that though she's got purple in
her hair
power big cameo right now but then wait
to doubly confirm her as the power
broker a character who is referred to
with male pronouns i mean she may just
represent whatever faction of hydra
is left after they were hunted down and
routed and julian louise
seems to be playing it with the same
kind of bry humor that gary chandling
played
senator stern i would have killed a
bastard too i mean you would have been
doing him a favor if you've taken out
the whole lot
yeah defontaine sounds like she's part
of some shadowy government agency
one without oversight without a public
face which yeah
sounds a lot like what nick fury
initially was doing with shield and
hydra did corrupt
shield so it is plausible that she could
be heading up a secret division of hydra
that's still active somewhere
perpetuated by zola's algorithm which
could mean
empty in my zola hand car could still
arrive at the station
i don't know it seems like marvel just
pulled a long time lesser-known comics
operative and plans to do something
entirely new with her
so it's not about her history it's about
the plan
you did the right thing you know
that's why i love this new rockstar [ __ ]
so much
because we have our experience with you
know when we talk about it a little bit
in our video
like way towards the end yeah you know
learn some things about her
she's associated with shield involvement
with nick fury sometimes romantically
and i was like oh that's cool and then
everywhere the next day when our videos
being edited
everyone's like man am i dramatic hydra
i'm like how did we miss madame hydra
yeah like we're we're in our research
that we miss
madame hydra what he does here is go
look guys
here's why it's not madame hydra well
yeah
i'm like between the femme force and the
leviathan
and shield nick fury and all these other
roles that she's had because that's what
everyone's saying is madame hydra i
totally missed that we were researching
her yeah
so it's definitely learned a lot from
new rock stars you know is it 100
this will be the one taking the serum
of course i know about that it has made
you very
very valuable to certain people hmm
which
certain people she plays what is that
indigo streak in her hair
i think defontaine could be at least
partly inspired by
high-ranking shield agent victoria hand
in the comics
deputy director of the thunderbolts
initiative during the dark reign now
victoria already appeared in agents of
shield which kevin feige has been kind
of indicating
ain't really mcu cannon but since we
already saw that character in a mobile
tv show maybe they're pulling a
different female shield
operative from marvel comics either way
it's not just the hair it's the fact
that she
values walker because he took the serum
and she knows government secrets
and the dorm elijah are taking zemo to
the raft prison
remember that that was a facility from
captain america overseen by
thaddeus ross whose name appears in the
end credits of the show
associated with the enhanced humans act
and we know from the first hulk film
that ross was deeply interested in
rebooting the super soldier program
defontaine could work for ross
thunderbolt ross
so recruiting yeah i just won't be
surprised if this season
ends with zemo on the raft and john
walker in the cell next to him as
defontaine strolls past them offering
them a chance for redemption through the
thunderbolts initiative where they can
join forces with
other forgotten marvel villains like
ghost like agatha harkness
don't tell me you don't want to see
julie louie driver absolutely
that would be pretty cool yeah it's like
the amazing spider-man 2
ending but done properly really built up
and took its time
and it would also carry on the motif of
mirroring
older installments but in new and darker
ways you know like we had to work to
assemble the avengers and
with that initiative and then we could
have the thunderbolts initiative of
anti-heroes coming together
i mean the second they said zemo is
going to the wrath
okay we're definitely building up
thunderbolts and i love the idea of jaw
walker being in the cell next to him and
then
him being part of thunderbolts that'd be
pretty cool with like why russell could
carry
continue to carry on here i mean i i
feel like he's made such a splash that
it would be unfortunate for him not to
carry on in some way
kariyama you don't get
it away with yourself all right yeah
sorry john
if you were here right now i'd be
touching myself i hate myself for that
feeling
zemo visits the sokovian memorial that
he mentioned in episode three this is
one honoring the victims of the battle
of sokovia and asia of ultron which
includes zemo's family
actually that lake behind it looks like
one formed by the runoff from the
upended terrain as the city was lifted
and zemo's music from tower returns here
do you think that's true
that's a such a specific detail i mean
if this is a monument to commemorate the
lives lost i could see it being in that
place
shirt design in our merch store dot com
it looks amazing very cool design and
you can get that next one i'm buying new
has a accessory.com sacobean eagle on it
with a base
showing russian letters that last word
translates to sokovia i think now
interestingly
in the december trailer this shot
included a ton of flowers notes and
flags at the base of the statue
and was not yet surrounded by a wall of
names or have a paved surface
i get those other changes but why remove
the flowers well perhaps the flowers
were laid for more recent sokovian
victims of
a global pandemic and whatever that
removed
december but maybe they didn't get
around to updating this shot in
particular yet
now bucky holds himself to rule number
two by not harming zemo handing them
over to the door
i mean they're just flowers i had a
memorial for dead people
yeah that makes sense that there'd be
flowers there a lot of people died
yeah and i feel like you know people
would still be feeling the effects of
that fallout i'm just saying like
with that other pandemic idea that they
have talked about like the storyline
they had to trim out of the series why
would flowers indicate such a thing
uh because it was recently deceased i
think too triggering
i think they wouldn't have caused any
interest at all
had they not disappeared
because they disappeared now we're
talking about
it because absolutely it's a monument to
a recent tragedy of course people would
still put flowers and flags on it but
then again
also if there was some kind of pandemic
ravaging the world i could also see
flowers and flags for that
maybe they just reworked the look of
that scene for some reason
it's all in the flowers man flowers
i got the darkness is flowers now bucky
holds himself to rule number two by not
harming zemo handing him over to the
dora melange
we will take him to the raft where he
will live out his days
and i like how they come and go in that
wakandan talon fighter that we saw in
black panther so sam revisits eli
bradley
future young avenger patriot and his one
father isaiah
he carries the shield what's more in
that art case that steve had it in
and game a nod to his sketching hobby
isaiah cites the red tails the famous
332 referring to the 332nd to the george
lucas film
world war ii but as the scene goes on it
is a
heartbreaking and challenging scene in
which he shares more about his
own tragic history a handful of us
got shot up with different versions of
that serum
they tell us it's tethnis
so this episode gets its title truth
from the comic series truth red white
and black which explores isaiah's
bradley's erased history as
the black captain america and with this
tetanus line sounds like this show is
referencing the horrific tuskegee
experiments in which the government
promised black sipless patients free
healthcare but actually just gave them
placebos and let them
die isaiah goes on to talk about his
missions during world war ii
every time i hear about that i heard
the brass talking about blowing the
p.o.w
camp to hell to hide the evidence and i
brought them boys back
yeah think about it this mirrors steve
rogers rescue steve rogers
was not funny hundreds of pows that were
written off as dead pretty much but
instead of the heroic greeting that
steve got
isaiah was freaking tortured and
imprisoned for 30 years isaiah talks
about his eventual escape
there was a nurse she took pity on me
wrote up some fake reports something she
had me declared
dead actually we might have seen that
fake death report for isaiah
bradley in the end credit sequence so
sam goes back to louisiana he helps fix
the family vote with some help from
bucky
who brings new gear design man that
isaiah bradley stuff is so great how
they've me
how they managed to really implement
that into this series you know it
wouldn't have worked for
any of the other captain american movies
but to include him here
it's powerful and it's crazy to know
that all that political stuff that
isaiah bradley talks about
is in the source material
no i'm pretty sure that's just disney
that's just disney
[Laughter]
and it is pretty gnarly to think that
was one of the top comments in our video
it was about how captain america i
forgot that cap did
no i didn't i said it and you would
never forget in the video i said like
that's everything that happened like
steve rogers got the exact
i said something i didn't forget you
just forgot that you remembered
i forgot that i remembered in the heat
of the moment which really helped me out
with looking
better and then i just kind of forgot
that i
was the heat helps fix the family boat
with some help from bucky who brings new
gear designed by cgi black
kind of kept a mystery pulp fiction
style you know
they are kind of like uh a jules and
vince vega huh
yeah a little bit vic vega who's vince
do i know vince vega i don't know
it's vic vega though what's uh no vince
blonde's name though vic yeah those are
terrible parents
hey man some families out there loved it
john and ron
yeah you either get rhyming names or
every name starts the same place my son
craig
and craig craig greg
and egg
you never know where these pauses are
gonna take you some of them are gonna be
rich with the commentary others are
gonna be
golden jokes
i'm guessing we're gonna see new
vibranium wings and
vibrations we're gonna incorporate the
shield so that sam can feel comfortable
carrying it without feeling like he has
to live up to cap
in fact i think that could be the deeper
meaning of this line why didn't you use
the metal arm
well i don't always think of it
immediately
oh please if it weren't for me bad truck
we call him bat rock
yeah it's my favorite genre of music
this time now mt speaks a bit of prince
he was able to translate batroc's rant
as saying that he lost his team on the
last mission and that he would never
work for sharon again hey thanks mt but
this confirms that batroc's mission in
episode one was in fact orchestrated by
sharon carter and her criminal operation
in madrid now again i would be surprised
if sharon is revealed to be the power
broker herself not just because of the
pronouns but because zemo knew the power
broker before he was imprisoned in civil
war
before sharon broke bad and really
sharon seems like too much of a foot
soldier for
a godlike crime boss with spooky murals
that's what she
wants you to think sister
or the power broker may be trying to
undermine maybe she's gender maybe
she's sending that truck in to help the
flag smashers in their mission against
the grc so that bat truck can gain their
trust and then lure them back to sharon
and the power broker but
check out this painting in her art
collection this is the wrap
it's a friend i love that transition
yeah
yeah i know sherry carter might be this
it might be this but check out this
place
i mean we've been doing some easter eggs
but have you seen fine art
painting in her art collection this is
the raft of the medusa it's a french
romantic painting depicting the infamous
wreckage of the french naval
frigate the medusa i don't know leave
that to empty to get that right this is
a real ship
in history i ran aground and then had a
super incompetent captain that led the
crew to starve and get super dehydrated
and start eating each other so with all
the focus on it here maybe sharon
actually has plans to
stage a mutiny on her crime boss the
power brokers
failure
sleeps on the couch instead of on the
floor definitely a sign of improvement
and they play some cats in someone
else's home
well that chair is too small to sleep in
feels weird
sam is calling back his words to steve
love the way this shield
shot how does it feel weird
they've lost somebody look at someone
else's damn notice
okay it's momentum a little recoil
not only is bucky stronger with his arms
yeah he does it but this shield is also
an
awkward it's good to catch still get a
heavier historical weight based off of
the dark truths that isaiah bradley left
him with but then bucky reveals
when steve told me what he was planning
i don't think either of us really
understood what it felt like for
the black man to be handed the shield
yeah this confirms that bucky and steve
did talk over that shield succession
off-screen during end game but also
interestingly that old cap remembered
that plan throughout his entire
alternate life before rejoining them but
i could see a scenario here that would
piss off so many people
where that push-in shot they were doing
on bucky we never thought about what it
might be like for a black man
to take on the shield and if
anthony mackey is not nominated for an
emmy but sebastian stands up
i i only i kind of how triggering would
that be
i wish i could visit that timeline just
to see what happens on twitter the
second that runs
multiverse interestingly that old cap
remembered that plant throughout his
entire alternate life before rejoining
them bucky brings back up steve's
notebook and sam says
but steve is gone and this might be a
surprise but
it doesn't matter what steve thought so
does gone mean
dead retired returned to another
timeline or on the moon like torres
thinks i mean just show us the freaking
headstone for the old man and leave the
door open to younger cap in the
multiverse and we'll be done with it
sam tells about today there's a true way
to make amends
probably setting up bucky to return to
old mr nakajima and tell him the truth
about his son
next episode and then sam's looking hot
as he's working out with that shield
in tompkins square park in new york
somehow getting into the us despite
being highly sought after terrorists
whatever
batroc hooks them up with some weaponry
and their new recruits disrupt a meeting
with the grc who are trying to vote on
the patch act which was told to us in a
news report on w-h-i-h
presumably it'll be here in new york
that all these warring parties will meet
including which stands for what the hell
is happening and john walker with his
new homemade
shield he actually hammers that together
in this episode's post-credits scene
now actually another big mcu title ends
the same way with credit says just go to
black and you hear the clanging of a
hammer avengers endgame
remember who brought you this disney
brought you this
in the person a scrap this scene is a
reference to that as well
in walker's man cave now here walker
melts down the congressional medal of
honor
that we actually now he's gonna try to
be iron man and mess that up too yeah
he's gonna be trying to be every avenger
yeah seriously i am iron man he's gonna
start dressing in tight black spandex
he's gonna have an iron man suit a bow
and arrow the shield
now here walker melts down the
congressional medal of honor that we
actually saw him holding this
earlier and he uses this to fuse
together the metal of the shield now
while i doubt this shield is made of
vibranium or anything stronger
by being made of the military metals it
does bear a deeper more personal
significance for walker we heard him
repeat
throughout this episode
i am captain america and this man's
gonna be captain america in his own mind
even if he has to cosplay to do it but
my favorite detail of this final shot
is once again hidden in his hands as he
spray paints that metal ring
he coats his thumb in a dark red not
at all caring about the blood red stains
that he gets
on his hands and yes this is our anarchy
assembled shirt
also available at newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter
follow new rockstars subscribe to new
rockstars here on youtube
breakdown everything marvelous thank you
for watching bye
bye bye eric i'll see you next week see
you next week buddy i love you eric
ah dude that is pretty
gnarly he should have a welding career
he's he's a great metal worker and he
should hone in on those talents that
he's naturally been given not not super
soldier
junk i think it's really bold what
marvel has done like a toying playing
with fire on
the image of captain america's existence
within the mcu
you know what i mean you get such
different feelings whenever you see john
walker who's gone down this horror movie
path
i am captain america you all know
i'll be better than steve rogers you
know you will
love me and then whenever you cut the
footage of actual captain america steve
rogers
you just get hit with this like warmth
and nostalgic feeling
it's like if if there's someone in a
leadership position
who you loved and then there's a new
person in that leadership position
and then you're like oh i hate this guy
do you remember what the other guy was
like oh so much better you're not a
leader at all you're not the leader i
love we should go back to that leader
yeah yeah there's something about steve
rogers he's just like you're yeah like
your grandpa who always had the good
advice or something like that he's a
great person man
he was a good guy i miss steve so with
that i think it's really cool to mess
with the captain america
like just with the image of it like
you're not messing with steve rogers
yeah but you know like now the word
captain america i feel like has
such a different meaning now because of
the show yeah well and not just because
of john walker
but because of the exploration really of
like what erskine was trying to do
with choosing the right person to take
on the super soldier serum what this is
really doing is exploring what the
meaning of the shield is and what the
meaning of captain america is and the
different interpretations that one could
associate with it and i think
that's just really cool to do that and
it and it's
you could just kind of be like chris
evans man he was great
but now you have this like different
exploration of what it means to be
captain america and i think that's
really neat well yeah and it's smart
that they've you know throughout the
captain america franchise infused more
and more of these espionage and
geopolitical themes because then it does
take on what the source material is sort
of trying to comment on but also i think
it's interesting too from a just a film
standpoint because now we are
getting to witness the benefits of
having such a presence built up over so
much time with steve rogers like it's
it's so solidified in anybody who's been
watching's memory
that now yeah like the symbol is there
and established
and now you can kind of freely probe it
in a way that yeah isn't going to
dismantle the legacy of steve rogers in
fact it's gonna
make it stronger in a lot of ways with
contrast and i think that's
a unique thing that only a franchise
built this way
or that has some kind of long-lasting
association can do so yeah like i'm
i'm excited for the future of captain
america
properties just because it seems like
now especially we can take the glove
like i feel like the when you're first
doing captain america you have to really
be like
who's the ideal captain america we have
to nail that yeah
and now that we've done that with grace
yeah we could do whatever
you know we could try all kinds of
things it might be some of the best
storytelling ever done
where an audience can actually get on
board with perhaps
and perhaps accepting someone being
handed off the baton
yeah like the handing off the baton
thing sucks and [ __ ] and this is
actually like
ooh like when they had those final
moments with falcon i'm like
that's my new captain america that's
what i've realized is the brilliance of
this series
so so many times the transition is
literally we made a new casting choice
and then the next time you see them
they're going to take up the mantle and
beat the thing and it's
actually i'm realizing how brilliant i
think it is that they took
sam you know who has been offered the
mantle and bucky as well
and put them in this scenario where the
whole debate of the show is they chose a
guy
right away plugged him in and now you
know the world is kind of getting to
have a response not the same response
but you know an
adverse response the way fans might to a
casting change or something like that
obviously with much greater context
heaped on top of it but then you know as
a means of really
it's like at the end of end game i was
like damn what what is it gonna be like
for sam to take up the shield
and i love that yeah the whole point is
getting to the decision for him to do
that
and making us want him to make the
decision
through this whole series like yeah it's
really clever cool right
yeah it's cool this is literally getting
us on board yeah
that's what i mean over six episodes
that's exactly my point and
it hit me in the last episode what's
going on all right guys well we took
time to actually talk seriously when
most people have left the video
it's a reward for you guys thank you
rockstars for putting this together
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button
and thank you to skillshare for
sponsoring this video use that code
much love